hey guys Pete here is that future or is
it past here we are again right back
where we started
what's going on with Agent Dale Cooper
this is gonna be more of a reaction in
thoughts video because I have so much on
my mind I'm not yet in a top moment kind
of mode honestly I am stunned by the
finale and that's the only way I can
describe the feeling real quick if you
wandered in here by accident and haven't
picked up on it yet this is your spoiler
warning if you haven't finished twin
peak season 3 yet this video will spoil
it all so run now while you still can
all right anywho so I finished part 17
and 18 of Twin Peaks the return and here
we are I was captivated on the edge of
my seat I was happy I was sad I was
excited I was scared I had hope I was
let down and at the end I was
overwhelmed by the mystery stunned
we started out getting everything we
wanted but I think about all your
questions from last week it was almost
like a checklist of reveals in the
beginning of this experience first and
foremost we found out that Gordon Cole
had been keeping something from Albert
for the past 25 years before he
disappeared major Briggs had shared
something with him in coop and that was
that he'd found an entity an extreme
negative force called in olden times
djal Day which over time had become Judy
Gordon Cooper and major Briggs put
together a plan to get Judy but then
something happened to major Briggs and
then something happened to Cooper Philip
Jeffries who doesn't really exist
anymore also told Cole a long time ago
that he was on to this entity and then
he disappeared so at this point
everything's going smoothly I mean we
don't find anything out about Chet
Desmond but otherwise we get a large
serving of answers here Cole adds that
Cooper told him that he was trying to
kill two birds with one stone and that
if he disappeared they needed to do
whatever they could to find him all big
stuff but I don't want to get stuck here
for
too long because the next thing that
happens is Bushnell reads coops note to
Cole over the phone it says that he's on
his way to sheriff Truman's it's 253 in
Las Vegas that adds up to a 10 which is
the number of completion Blue Rose task
force looks into why Dougie is Cooper
and then they pack it up because Gordon
knows where he's headed from there we
get into a string of payoffs which is
why I don't want to do a top moments
video yet
I need to rewatch before I can do that
and I've got some burning questions
going on in my head the quick recap is
that evil coupe gets sucked into a
vortex by the Jackrabbits palace
location he's trapped in a cage briefly
in the firemen's theater with major
Briggs his head floating nearby the
giant aka the fireman sends him to Twin
Peaks where he goes to the sheriff's
department and is greeted by an
enthusiastic Andy and taken in to talk
to Sheriff Frank
Lucy ends up shooting him which brings
on the woodsman the Bob orb eventually
pops out just as the real agent Cooper
arrives with the mitchum brother
entourage Freddy uses the green globe to
kill Bob I think I think he killed Bob
isla Schneider turns out to be the real
Diane which a lot of people had guests
and she and Cooper share a passionate
kiss before he leaves calling for Gordon
to come with them after he gets the
Great Northern key from the sheriff
the trio goes into the basement of the
Great Northern where coop enters the
door that has that sound coming from
inside of it inside he's met by Mike aka
Phillip Gerard aka the one-arm man taken
to Phillip Jeffries who's still a steam
kettle teapot kind of thing which sends
him back in time to the night that Laura
Palmer died Cooper saves her by stopping
her from meeting up with jock Leo and
Ron net we get a cool sequence where we
see the next morning happening again but
this time Laura isn't dead and wrapped
in plastic when Pete goes fishing we
actually see fatigue get to fish
and it's a pretty awesome scene to give
us the idea of what happened we see her
disappear as a way of pointing out that
history has been changed this gives us
the beginning and understanding why
there were so many inconsistencies in
the secret history of Twin Peaks but
brings up about a gazillion other
questions at the same time on top of
that just as we're thinking everything
is moving towards a happy resolution the
rug is pulled out from underneath us we
see the Palmer House here's some ominous
moaning off-screen and then see that
it's coming from Sarah Palmer aka Judy
who starts smashing Laura's photo with a
bottle on the carpet breaking the glass
in the frame from there we cut to coupe
and Laura walking towards that
Jackrabbits palace location and we kind
of realized that this is going on at the
same time from what we see Sarah doing
because we hear the electrical noise and
then she disappears screaming we get our
Julie crews outro that we've been
waiting for and that ends part 17 for
the most part I kind of think part 17
bleeds into the beginning of part 18 but
we'll talk about that later and part 18
we see evil coupe get destroyed in the
Red Room Dougy coupe remade by Mike and
real Cooper ends up getting sucked back
in the new dougie Jones is sent back to
Janie II and sunny Jim and after repeat
of Laura whispering in his ear and a
talk with Leland real Cooper leaves the
red room where the real Diane is outside
waiting I say the real cupen Diane
because they ask each other that
question and at this point it seems real
after that we find him driving down a
highway and learn they're travelling to
exactly 430 miles away there are these
great big powerlines there and after
saying that everything might be
different after they go and cross over
they go ahead and actually do it where
they go is up for debate but we'll call
it an alternate dimension for simplicity
sake in this dimension Laura is still
alive but she's actually not really
Laura Cooper and Diane the real Cooper
and Diane go
they're together but Cooper doesn't
resemble himself really once they get
into the motel room they check into this
motel they have sex
and when koop wakes up alone in the
morning we find out that he is actually
Richard and Diane was actually Linda in
this dimension and there were definitely
telling signs that he wasn't himself if
you go back and watch you'll see that he
is the whole thing from this point out
he seems different does that mean that
he's evil coop again I don't really
think so but that's another rabbit hole
to go down later on so he tracks down
Laura who is actually Carrie page she
doesn't know what Richard coupe is
talking about but because she has a dead
guy in her living room
she decides it's a good idea to go with
him anyways and they drive off to Twin
Peaks when they get to the Palmer home
we find out that a family named tremon
lived there and that they bought it from
the Chow fonts
those are both aliases of the older
woman who had the grandson you know the
one that gave Laura the photo of the
doorway that to hang on her wall none of
this seems familiar to Laura until they
go out into the street then coupe says
what year is this and that sent
something off in her like I don't know
what happens but it's a trigger she
looks up at the house we hear her mother
Sarah say Laura the same sound clip that
we heard in the pilot it's really faint
in the background but it's there and
then Laura starts to shake and after
that she starts to scream the house
flashes and the screen goes black and
quiet until music comes up and then the
credits eventually roll bringing the
return to an end and like I said at the
beginning we are exactly where we were
when season 3 or if you don't want to
call it season 3 I would understand that
at this point the return started is
agent Cooper really agent Cooper why is
Laura the one did she remember or should
I say did Carrie Paige remember it all
has a familiar feeling only in my
personal opinion here I don't actually
think this is a cliffhanger I think at
the end of season 2
that was deliberate it was to have a
continuation to keep the show going this
isn't exactly feel the same to me when
part 18 switches whenever they leave the
Red Room and then cross over to me it
feels like it's a completely different
story at that point on the one hand but
it's also an answer to the story like
think about it
agent Cooper did all that he did to try
to change something after he changed it
he ended up in a different dimension
where even though it was changed it
wasn't necessarily better and I saw some
comments on my Twitter feed and
different places already where people
some people definitely don't like this
and some people will definitely not like
this and they're gonna not really listen
to anything to the contrary I think
there's going to be another pretty
heavily populated group of people who
insist that there's gonna have to be
another season because of where things
let off I think it does leave the door
open to the story going in that way but
I don't think that that was the case I
think once the book comes out we'll have
a better idea of what the blue roze task
force was doing and some of the gaps
that were in that but if you think about
it that's not the real history anymore
like we can't go back to the original
Twin Peaks that we knew in season one or
season two or fire walk with me because
it literally doesn't exist the only way
it could exist at this point is if Laura
was killed again
maybe so my initial reaction was like I
said it was stunned then I started to
think about it more when I started to
write this and I'm not gonna say that I
understand it or that it doesn't need to
have a lot more of a look because I
think there's a lot of great stuff here
to break down just like we've been doing
but I think I kind of understand how
they ended up where they ended up I
think people are gonna give David Lynch
a ton of credit for putting this
together and give him most of the kudos
but I think that there's a really strong
undercurrent of mark frost in this that
is basically essential like if you think
about that dream that Monica Bellucci
dream who is
dreamer Dale Cooper is the dreamer he
changed things because he saw something
that was wrong and the story of Twin
Peaks is still kind of the same you know
what I mean it's rearranged but it's
still this quaint little place that you
love where some really evil stuff goes
on and so in that way as a narrative of
like if you don't think about individual
plot points and you just think about it
as a story I feel like I kind of get it
that way and I also get that when I was
watching it the entire time I was
completely riveted and compelled to talk
about it break it down look at it wait
for the next episode and thoroughly
enjoyed the ride of it so am i upset
that we didn't find out what was going
on with Audrey well I mean I think I
kind of covered it whenever I did my
other video about her she's probably
stuck in some kind of large place or at
least she was in the reality that
existed before lore before
koop went back in time and saved Laura
after that we're not really owed like a
description of what you know what's
going on sure we'd like it I would like
it I'm not saying that I'm you know not
interested but you know what I mean it's
not it wasn't the point where Audrey was
wasn't the point the point was is that
we were supposed to have this experience
and it's very true to the original
series when you think about it times
have changed
TV went way forward since then but
instead of it like being you know the
original series we like because it was
different that you know it was a
different take on what was popular on TV
this is kind of the same thing like when
everything was falling into place and I
thought we were coming to like a
satisfying resolution where everything
made sense and everybody was happy it
didn't exactly feel right so I don't
know I'm interested to see what you guys
think the big burning questions I have I
mean there were 13 actors credited in
part 18 and most of the main ones were
done by the end of the first eight
minutes
Diane leaves the story around the 20
minute mark and then it's really just
coop and Laura and some supporting cast
there so we're gonna say that in that
different dimension my big question is
is
what exactly happened to coupe was he
changed by crossing over
did he leave part of himself behind you
know what I mean like I think he was a
different person so I'd be interested to
see what you guys think about that he
didn't he wasn't sharp he wasn't he
wasn't like as hyper focused on doing
the right thing so after watching evil
coupe all season it kind of seemed like
he had some of those characteristics but
he was still at his core Dale Cooper I
think that judy is synonymous with the
experiment or the mother and I think
that Judy is and was inside Sarah Palmer
at least on the first watch I'd have to
go back and watch again and really kind
of dissect that but that's the part that
or that's the feeling I have coming away
from it do you think that those scenes
that we saw like where we saw a Bobby
and the accident and the girl puking and
the red stuff do you think those were
literal glimpses into this reality that
exists now or this dimension or this
world or whatever you want to call it or
do you think that was just along the way
to really make us think about the nature
of reality in general so yeah I'm gonna
have to go back and re-watch I'm gonna
do that ASAP I wanted to throw this out
and get your response this is my initial
reaction today and we'll see what
happens after I have a good night's
sleep and everything else so let me know
what you think please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel and turn on notifications and I
asked you guys about patreon and I
started one so I'd love it if you guys
came over and joined me over there after
I get through this finale stuff I'll be
coming up with ideas of how to move
forward with Twin Peaks now that the
season's over
and I'll be taking advice from my
patrons over there I'll be doing some
polls and seeing how we're gonna move
forward so definitely check that out let
me know if you have any questions and
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon